that's a DMV our crack team of
journalist uncover the most important
news Kim Kardashian shoes two weeks old
this is the biggest news since man
walked on the moon
right because Danby we're really
important Jennifer Love Hewitt has so
you like cellulose you front-page
jennifer Love Hewitt's shows cellulite
she cares nothing for the world
I am also about him bear you're like but
they're nothing without us
Brad Pitt taking his kids to school he's
like a person or something look like you
can just live life like the rest of us
damn day you'll need to know this or
you'll die now let's see if our newest
member has anything to say just Andhra
critic what do you got
it's a time for commercial yet
these are the exact same instructions
you give a prostitute a mr. critic isn't
as much better than mocking us on your
website yeah well it was very kind of
your people to get in contact with our
people let us know that you didn't like
the way we represented you it's good to
know that industry that machs so many
has such a thick not hypocritical skin
themselves well I'm just glad you took
our offer to come down here for a day
and see that we conduct very important
very serious work and I thought I'd take
a chance and hope that one of us could
learn the meaning of the word fair I
guess it was too optimistic to assume
both of us would Jennifer Lopez was
caught with nose hairs Amy back from my
key bar
it's not easy representing someone let
alone to work maybe Steven Spielberg
show thought Emily took over Stanley
Kubrick's long-awaited fairytale and
this was no easy task
Kubrick director of a Clockwork Orange
2001 a Space Odyssey and Spielberg
hawky all know who he is where as far in
the opposite ends of the directing
spectrum as you could possibly get
Kubrick was cold and dark Spielberg was
whimsical an enchanting Kubrick was slow
and eerie Spielberg was peppy and upbeat
stylistically there were practically
nothing alike the only thing the two did
seem to have in common is that at times
they surprisingly me2 each other
Spielberg often longed to be that
arthouse risk-taker that Kubrick was and
Kubrick often longed to be the audience
pleasing sentimentalist that Spielberg
was so when Kubrick was going through
years and years and writer after writer
perfecting his vision of what he would
call his sci-fi version of Pinocchio
he felt he didn't have the talent to
pull off the emotional heart needed and
hated directing over to Spielberg while
Kubrick would produce it Spielberg
thought he didn't have the talent to
pull off the calculated artistry needed
and handed it back to Kubrick while he
would produce it being friends for years
they each made the argument that the
other was better to direct until Kubrick
finally caved in and said after his film
Eyes Wide Shut a I would be the next
film he would do and just to make things
even more complicated Kubrick
so Spielberg thought it best that he'd
bring the legendary director's
masterwork to life himself resulting in
the awkward unfocused and confused low
trainwreck we all know as AI with the
style of two totally different directors
being juggled this film is about as big
a mess as you can imagine if you find
yourself paying less attention to the
story and instead focusing more on is
that a Kubrick move or a Spielberg move
and instead of being one artists great
masterpiece we get visual backwash and
emotional hand-me-down to replace raw
feelings and ideas so let's see how the
master of art represents the master of
art this is AI so we open the story
about a human robot with hollywood's own
human robot William Hurt all over you
working he plays the head of a business
that makes androids and he's looking to
create an Android that's actually
capable of love I propose that we build
a robot child who can love a robot child
who will genuinely love the parent or
parents it imprints on with a love that
will never end
hmm interesting idea raising a lot of
interesting questions how do you program
love can it be programmed what's the
difference between love and desire is
there a difference can it be technically
defined and if it can't can you assume
you can properly create it does love
only work if it's shared equally all of
these questions and more will be thrown
to the kinda category as we have to
establish this future that clearly
exists only to justify our characters
idiot moves for example in this
post-apocalyptic world
yeah it's about as post-apocalyptic as a
Betty Crocker commercial pregnancy must
be sanctioned to keep population under
control after the ice caps melted this
is rough seeing how one couple has to
keep their child frozen because he's
suffering from we need to keep you out
of the first 20 minutes itis and thus
they seemed like the perfect parents to
try out their new boy-toy
I like your floor this is David played
by Jesus you're scary Haley Joel Osment
who's been allowed to be their son
this imprinting is irreversible the
robot childs love would be sealed in a
sense hardwired and would be part of him
forever
yeah great plan right I mean can you see
anything going wrong with this idea
ethical scarring emotional crippling me
I just see playing catch don't plant
until you're entirely sure now what you
might notice very quickly is that
Spielberg has done a pretty decent job
recreating the cinematography of
Kubrick's work it actually mirrors a lot
of techniques that Kubrick has done in
the past oh I know Cooper hust it once
in a while so people will call me a
genius when I use it all the time what
he hasn't captured though is the editing
or the tone Kubrick would let a lot of
his shots go on for a while building an
uncomfortable mood and allowing you to
enjoy the visuals or movement but
Spielberg cuts his shots just like any
other movie making his way for quirky
scenes like this which very likely would
not end up in a typical Kubrick
production
stop
yep I think if Kubrick was directing
this we all know how this scene would go
come play with me mommy but it's okay
David finally finds a way to win over
his mother's affection what you would
shit your pants and throw the fucking
thing away well not our mother she
figures that's enough to push the I love
you forever button which programs the
child to never stop obsessing over her
till the end of his days
boy if they knew that was the selling
point for most parents they'd have them
laugh at even more things hey take a
look Keyes housing foreclosure chassis
Morgan
oh he's a keeper so David is now
programmed to love only his mom but not
his dad so much seeing how he never
refers to him as dad hello David oh ouch
I just will change his name to I'm not
your sperm David also gets a new
playmate a little toy named teddy hello
daddy hello David why does that create
uncomfortable flashbacks
this is the end
my cuddly friend the yes this is the end
Oh
David teddy is a super toy and I know
you'll take good care of each other I am
NOT a toy teddy is my slave name
you may call me cuddly Kinte but though
that pesky real son wakes up and
apparently is not thrilled about robotic
replacement doing terrible things like
forcing his mother to read horribly
ironic stories his favorite being
Pinocchio David's going to love it but
David ends up liking this story
particularly the part about where the
Blue Fairy turns Pinocchio into a real
boy a pipsqueak mcbean bull fuck
constantly reminds him that he's not a
real boy so fighting for his mother's
attention he tries eating spinach to
convince that he is real you will break
Zen man servation from Teddy or threat
I must predict you does he eat fish
Martin you're provoking him David stop
it
oh no they use Photoshop smear we need
heavy-duty Mario Party for this
he gets fixed up but scheme emic weasel
bitch has yet another plan I want a lock
of mommy's hair I'll share it with you
and if you had it important
she might love him even more the Ranger
isn't gonna like this yogi he tries
cutting off the hair but ends up looking
like a poster child for Lizzie Borden's
barber school which ends up getting the
parents concerned if he was created to
love and it's reasonable to assume he
knows how to hate and if pushed to those
extremes what is he really capable of
and more importantly why did another
scientist putting him together
everything else why is it every story
where someone wants to play God they're
always like in those questions will just
go away why does nobody in movies ever
think of the consequences consequences
response questions as long as I'm rich
but through misunderstanding number 20
David becomes afraid of some bullies
heights behind his brother and they both
fall into the pool resulting in his
brother almost getting killed so I guess
it's finally time to bring him in and
have the scientists look at a lot of
these kinks going on huh no CIM yeah no
there's no other alternative he's got to
die just hop in your mechanical hot dog
in town were taking a trip to the
liquidation Factory come on zan easy
choice it's not like anybody would grow
attached to him with his big puppy-dog
eyes and isn't smile and will to love
past the end of time I mean Jesus what
have kids in the 90s had to get rid of
their fur bees the exact same way
teddy no I'm sorry son but you read the
instructions once he starts
malfunctioning he has to be bludgeoned
to death as violently as possible but I
laugh oh now don't tell me you want to
see the therapist again
where are we going what's ready tonight
tell me about the rabbits George I I
have to leave you here I have to go stop
no I'm sorry
this emotional meat tenderizer to your
nads is not warranted there's a
bajillion other ways around this we
program him change the settings wipe his
memory adjust his abilities be more
specific in your commands nothing about
this makes any sense
I think the only way it would make even
less sense isn't Batman showed up and
said I pulled his brother into the pool
sorry I didn't tell you about the world
and if his mother loved him so much she
wouldn't leave him to roam alone in this
dangerous world she sorry she never
taught him about she wouldn't know it's
much worse to leave him alive knowing
he'll never see her again
then it is just to shut him off I mean
come on Spielberg Cooper covered his
tracks better than this I mean what
human being would be so Anson minded and
so cruel okay people story time duty
calls
damn BAE we dedicate our lives to make
sure you were all right boys go
I was diggin to Leonardo DiCaprio's
garbage and I found McDonald's Oh he
eats food obviously someone's in
financial tip Bella Papa I'm dominant
damn babe Weasley motive guys I have a
picture of Natalie Portman with a
mustard stain on her shirt to shun her
we must shun her put that picture on the
front page the people must know him very
much as you dumbasses wanted Rick when
you got well I did find a story here
that a Sandra Bullock Sandra Bullock
will be honored for donating $25,000 to
the warren Essen charter high school
which was destroyed in Hurricane Katrina
no aji also opened an on-campus health
clinic there as well you say we want
about our shitty movies but that's
pretty cool right I mean that's really
big of her looks fat what shits really
fat mr. Norton new front page Sandra
Bullock ballooning the blind side of our
backside
get back our folks dear Brutus lies not
in Our Stars but in ourselves I mean we
trend men miss Lois what's wrong first I
get thought about doing real journalism
respecting my job could your bidding
something important people's lie miss
Lewis pull yourself together yeah your
job is bullshit if you don't report Emma
Watson possibly having a double jam then
who will
I just swallow your dignity and remember
you have no soul to lose okay good good
Tim bag we're cool really we're cool
so we cut to what I like to call movie
two because yeah from this point on it
is pretty much an entirely different
movie where we see Jude Law playing a
prostitute he's in trouble because he's
framed for a murder by a jealous
ex-lover
and thus is on the run because
apparently even though it's explained
very clearly that none of these robots
are able to have feelings they do seem
to have a need for self-preservation and
a need to form opinions and I need to be
sarcastic and a need to have distinct
personalities and a need to adapt and a
need to change and a need to interact
and a need to survive and a need to help
and I need to protect and I need to
fight and a need to lie and a need to
deceit and a need to what and I need to
desire and I need to do just about
anything a goddamn human being
emotionally needs to do but just to
emphasize again none of them have any
emotional feelings what so ever
yeah and Mel Gibson just drinks a little
too much coffee he does no splash so
David comes across a bunch of robot
zombies which if that's not a thing
somebody make that a thing but they see
a bad moon rising which are actually
representatives of a flesh fair a
gathering of people who hate robots and
take ones who are no longer owned and
destroy them
okay I know we're trying to hammer in
the whole fairy tale thing but really
this is what we're doing for chased by
wolves is this really the best you got
cuz if you're gonna do that why don't
you just make Little Red Riding Hood a
gang on the east side with red hoodies
just posing for the camera to show off
that effect okay so they get caught in a
net yeah apparently these super-strong
robots greatest weakness is a net as
they drag him to the last place they
want to go to
welcome to the Kubrick Spielberg
collaboration everybody doesn't it look
exactly how you thought it would look
oh the artistic majesty oh the visual
wonder oh the Chris Rock Pot can you
kind of shoot me over the propeller
thing yeah I don't need to go food I was
considering it but I changed my mind
okay mr. Spielberg I'm not gonna act
like I'm the biggest aficionado want
Stanley Kubrick or anything but I'm just
gonna take a wild guess a wild fucking
guess that Stanley Kubrick the director
of 2001 a Clockwork Orange the shot
anyone but a dress my body there I mean
did you really think that was part of
the great masters vision really was one
of the agreements that you guys talked
about in making this film four years
that it cannot be made unless the
essential Chris Rock bot was in there
just somewhere anywhere the whole entire
thing would crumble if really a Chris
Rock bot or maybe Stanley Kubrick was a
big Chris Rock fan I mean who knows
maybe he could use them in all their
films it feels around back then open the
pod bay doors he'll open the doors now
what's the problem
crack-a-lackin' you got stuck down what
are you talking about I gotta get this
part right oh I'm gonna have nothing but
shitty movies for the rest of my life
how I would argue with you man but I
don't think you understand you've got
the gun Oh
I'll go in through the emergency airlock
what do you want okay
I mean it's lazy it's so fucking lazy I
mean what a TA would actually put
another meeting everyone sometimes I
wonder if Spielberg even understands
what means to represent someone fairly
alright guys because we have so many
important topics to get out there I
thought it'd be best if we select our
stories a little faster so I'm gonna
hold up a picture of a celebrity and I
think we should do a story on it then I
let on the collective grunt and if you
don't think that's a great idea
alright
so we would turn back to the flesh WWE
monster truck anti-gay marriage fair
when somebody thinks David shouldn't be
there your machine
impossible why he looks like every other
robot there at least the ones that look
human it's because there's never been a
robot child before 75 years at least of
androids and there's never been a robot
child the Chris Rock bot was more
important to make than a robot child I'm
sorry
unless he's a machine that also turns
water to absinthe I wouldn't buy them I
said that go I'm trying but just when it
looks like David and his prostate are
about to go to silicon heaven the
audience finds they just can't do it
mecha don't plead for their lives oh
really
did you not hear the comedic pleads of
the Chris Rock bot I'm sorry I know I'm
dwelling but really what was that so
they let him go and the prostitute his
new mission to find the Blue Fairy
rather than the prosthetist tell him
though I don't know there's no such
thing he says the answer lies in a
perverted little town known as Rouge
City they go through let's face it the
most awesome shot in the movie
and hitch a ride all the way down the
pg13 land a place that never would have
existed in Kubrick's world that's right
all of your wildest fantasies mildly
realized oh look at how sort of
stimulating that is oh look at how kind
of erotic that turns out ish Hey look
that almost looks like a nipple almost
and because the Internet apparently
doesn't exist in this future all of your
questions have to be answered by a
distracting Robin dr. Wylie williams
performance savvy minds welcome to dr.
know where fast-food for thought is
served up 24 hours a day in 40,000
locations nationwide question one
explain these I don't
but dr. Google it appears doesn't seem
to have the answers that David is
looking for where is Blue Fairy in the
garden Vasko stylist Blue Fairy Bloom's
twice annually with bright blue flowers
on a branched inflorescence come on just
a few years after this movie came out we
got the greatest search engines possible
and this incredible future thing can't
even tell if it means a flower a story
or whatever calorie let's be the AOL of
search engines but they finally asked
the right question and figure out that
the Blue Fairy apparently is at the
factory where David was created all the
way in New York City
kind of strange office location don't
you think is the commute difficult for
workers there hey Frank going to
destroyed ruin number five again nah I
think I'm upgrading to dangerously
unstable rubble number three you know
looking to move up in the world but
David goes inside the factory and
searches for himself
sort of Uriel I'm David you're not yes I
am so my let's be friends but I'm sure
kind loving David will find it in his
heart to find that he's unique in his
own wonderful I can't believe I know I'm
a machine I never realised they could
build another one of me why is so much
obvious logical information was out of
my memory banks why
but the bland pod comes in and explains
that everything that's happened to him
was all part of the plan the ability to
chase down our dreams and that is
something no machine has ever done until
you till you were born robots didn't
dream robots didn't desire unless we
told them what to want your ability to
want nothing but your mother even after
you were programmed to want nothing but
your mother is a break through I thought
I was one of a kind you are the first of
a kind
my brain is rolling out teams anxious to
talk to you want you to wait here I'll
gather the mother yes after killing your
robotic double destroying the room and
looking completely brain raped I'll
leave you here completely alone and
unattended what could go wrong well how
about this
David throws himself off the building
into the water we're quite fucking
coincidentally he finds a statue of the
Blue Fairy at an amusement park
Oh after being guided there by a school
of fish of course I don't know pasta pot
gets busted by authorities using a
magnet which doesn't suck up David for
some reason and David makes his way to
the blue fairy statue where he spends
the rest of his days following a dream
hoping it'll come true please even you
could argue creating faith possibly even
a religion thus making him much less
human but also even more human drawing
his journey to a close
two thousand years later oh yeah
don't act like you don't know what
happened even people who haven't seen
the movie know about the infamously
horrible continuation of a story that
everyone in the world said should not
continue it would have been fine if
they'd just left him in front of the
Blue Fairy everyone would have said yeah
it had problems but you know what it
could have been worse well this is the
worst they're talking about and it's not
just the fact that it continues when it
shouldn't it's the fact that it gives
the lamest the schmaltzy is preschool
friendly middle finger to anyone who may
have possibly liked this movie even a
little you all know what it is but just
for the hell of it let's go over it
aliens arrived oh wait no I'm sorry
robots that are never clarified as
robots unless you read the script and
discover David 2,000 years later frozen
in ice yeah apparently his circuits and
programming survived all the time the
longest lasting in human creation just
don't beat him spinach and with their
super not alien powers they create a
world for David to live in just like his
home and get this even the Blue Fairy is
there you have been searching for me
haven't you David now if you still
somehow managed to stay in your seed
after this information was made aware to
you I urge you not to turn around
because you probably noticed rows and
rows of empty seats and threatening
letters written in nosebleed blood as
that was the only thing that could serve
as ink at the time well mommy be coming
home soon
can never come home because 2,000 years
have passed and she is no longer living
yes our technology only extends to blue
fairy science we can bring inanimate
wood to life and give it a personality
based on your memory but the one thing
that takes up the most of your fucking
mind we can't materialize for some
reason we're kind of dumb not aliens
that way
we can bring back other people from your
time in the past why can't you bring
back her because we can only bring back
people whose bodies we dig up from the
ice we need some physical sample of the
person like a bone or a fingernail oh
yeah because the enchanting fairy tale
atmosphere is really completed with
talks of DNA samples and scientific
reanimation God Oh blue fairy is saying
this David do you remember when you cut
some of mommy's hair Oh Oh tell me Teddy
doesn't have it
tell me Teddy doesn't have it oh he does
he does trying to sink actually but I
won't question the motives behind a
children's toy who doesn't have motives
remember no feelings we clarify that ah
now you can bring her back your wish is
my command so joy of joys the Blue Fairy
can bring mommy back right well listen
to this horse cock those who were
resurrected only lived through a single
day of renewed life if we bring your
mother back now it will only be for one
day maybe the one day maybe it will last
forever
if you still managed to stay in your
seats after this information was made
aware to you I urge you again please
don't turn around because chances are
you be seeing the hanging dead corpses
of the film custodians the owner of the
theater hell maybe even the people who
made the popcorn I don't know just
whoever they could find
we only want for your happiness and you
know what you have to do listen can you
hear that go to her David oh so they
already brought her back to life they
were just fucking with him by giving him
the option I mean if he said no would
they have just eaten her or something
she wakes up in a Folgers commercial and
they intend to spend the whole day
together as if it was her last because
yeah that's the gist of it David had
never had a birthday party because David
had never been born so they baked a cake
and lit some candles no make a wish it
came true if you still manage to stay in
your seats after this information was
made aware to you I desperately urge you
do not turn around and look behind you
because chances are your theater is on
fire I don't know if you remember the
great AI theater burnings of 2001 but it
cost many movie goers their lives yet
the causes of the fire have still got a
refund and for the first time in his
life he went to that place
where dreams upon and teddy
well fuck teddy he's not real life David
he's just a bear a bear who wanted to
make David's dreams come true even
though he doesn't want anything
technically cuz he's just a machine who
cares about what David wants while not
caring what David wants I says I stupid
is I stupid attendant you could ever get
to a movie like this I mean by God who
are you even thinking were you even
thinking and we all know who's to blame
right we all know exactly who's to blame
for this schmaltzy crap Spielberg
he's so culprit we all know it it's got
to be Spielberg I mean obviously Kubrick
would have ended it under the water and
Spielberg added that last 15 minutes
there's no other explanation
wait just we'll get here just look at it
here yeah there you go
the writers were originally working on
AI who all thought it was crazy when
Kubrick wanted to bring David's mother
back what that ending was Kubrick's idea
in fact most of the original writers
thought it wouldn't work but Spielberg
did his best to work with him and get
across the idea he had in mind
so hubris to blame for that ending these
Stanley Kubrick The Shining a Clockwork
Orange bands of glory he's the one that
put together the incredibly sappy ending
Wow
maybe in the end Kubrick was trying to
make that Spielberg movie he never could
which ironically resulted in Spielberg
making that Kubrick movie America the
film is so disjointed and all over the
place and clearly not one vision but at
the same time bringing that vision to
life even though so many people were
against it just to make a close friends
dream come true
maybe he understood Cooper better than
we thought he did maybe he understood
him better than any of us maybe
representing a person's work and
representing a person himself are more
similar than we realized
who's that guy oh well that's stanley
kubrick sir Qbert I know that name well
you should he directed 2001 a Space
Odyssey Clockwork Orange The Shining
just to name a few and we looking up
about him oh just how Steven Spielberg
and him were friends and how he directed
a movie for him after he died and how
they might have actually been closer to
each other than a lot of people gave him
credit for hmm it sounds pretty good do
you mind if we use that for the topic of
this week's show sure go for it well
goes to show you again
some people can in fact surprise you in
the end next year Bay where Stanley
Kubrick and Steven Spielberg Abram on
another lock up Burton Ernie my research
shows that these two are all over each
other how can steal guard be all over
that fat blob well it's easier to
understand than have his crappy movies
yeah hello 2001 I mean like if I can't
understand it then that means it sucks
hey Creek where you doing well you guys
have opened my eyes you've shown me that
nothing is sacred I mean by God if you
can take stanley kubrick one of the
greatest directors of all time and make
a story about him like that I have no
choice you can't beat them join them
hey I stab suicides or at a new law well
everyone in light of the critics recent
breakthrough I think it's only fair that
we let him go first okay we got some
good stuff where's brick oh I do I do
yes I have drunken outbursts sexual
affairs cross-dressing some of the
sauciest stuff I've ever had to report
that all sounds pretty steamy critic
how'd you get so much footage of people
doing such rotten stuff oh it was quite
easy actually yeah I just followed all
of you what yeah yeah for example mr.
Aaron I got some lovely snapshots of you
cheating on your wife oh don't laugh too
much there mrs. Adams you're the one
who's having the affair with
and this Louisville who can forget that
enchanted evening that I recorded not 24
hours ago
and our dear beloved boss take a look at
what I recorded when you thought you
were alone and what you thought was a
closed-off
yeah not so hot when the two-week-old
shoe is on the other foot is it but you
want to know who the biggest idiot of
the ball is this guy right here yeah all
because of what he thought of this I
used to hate this movie I mean really
despise it I thought this was the worst
representation of a director simply by
choosing his opposite but I realize now
that Spielberg was going into a no-win
situation if he did it in his own style
everyone would say oh that's not like
Kubrick at all if he tried to mimic his
style everybody would say oh he's not
talented enough to mimic Kubrick but
maybe it wasn't about that maybe it was
just about bringing a man's dream to
life a dream that this man obsessed over
for years and years and a really good
friend didn't want to see go to waste
and even if it didn't come out that
great even if it was unfocused or cheesy
he still mimicked the director enough to
show that he understood him he still
created some interesting conversations
and ideas and you know what he fucking
tried he tried to the best of his
abilities to properly represent a person
who was very close to him which is more
than I can say for anyone in this room
maybe Kubrick moved out better maybe he
could have done worse help it's totally
possible for a great director to make a
bad film but when nobody can deny that
Spielberg did his best to make a
friend's dream a reality and nobody
fucking nobody can fault him for that
yeah well he's still fat well I guess it
doesn't matter all the world knows your
evil little secrets anyway but how do we
come back from this it how do we make
them forget well maybe if you ask all
the people on the internet over and over
to forget maybe just maybe your wish
will come true
please forget please forget please
forget please forget it well maybe the
longing for dignity is the beginning of
dignities I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it please don't you forget
please forget it I don't think it's
working let's try something more
positive
you
right